So we have a huge Nerf gun arsenal.
We're gonna show you guys the best Nerf guns.
We're gonna show you guys the worst Nerf guns.
We're gonna show you guys our special Nerf guns.
We got a lot, let's jump in.
I keep coming back to one Nerf gun over the years.
This one right here,
it's called, like, the Stryfe.
And that's because it's really small.
You can use it like as a rifle, you can put the stock on it
but also you can use it as a pistol.
This one is battery powered.
Super, super easy to mod.
That's why it's my favorite.
What is the best Nerf gun, in general?
That's an easy answer.
It's this gun.
This is, by far, the best Nerf gun
Nerf has ever made.
The second best Nerf gun
is the Hammershot.
Now, these guns seem very similar
But they have their own unique features.
This gun is super accurate,
it's a single shot,
it's kinda loud.
This gun, however,
you can pump with one hand.
Being able to do that makes all
the difference in the world.
You can dual wield and be pumping your guns
and shooting at the same time.
Also, this is, by far, the best stealth Nerf gun.
The Hammershot will never let you down.
I don't know what this was called.
It's one of the zombie strike,
like two shot ones.
This is, like, the best concealed Nerf weapon.
You can also fan the hammer.
I mean, I really like these ones
They were, like, the most reliable
for actually hitting people in games
where you're just like *gun noise, yo*
Compare that to, like, something like this
which has a motor in it
Way less stealthy. No stealth.
Runners up, here, is
the Slingfire, which is magazine fed
You can also, like, do the whole, like,
Terminator thing.
Which is fun.
It's just super reliable
and it shoots straight,
and it holds a lot of rounds.
You know, I think I have a good replacement
for that orange Nerf gun of yours, Sam.
This is, basically, the same Nerf gun
Oh you're right.
but way more stylish.
Yeah, they literally just re-skinned
the same Nerf gun
with "girl" colors.
'Cause I'm a girl~
How do you have so much style?
Uh I just have it.
Did you go over this one?
These little pea-shooters are actually
really accurate and they shoot really far.
Check this out.
*shoots invisible guy that's having lunch*
DAAAAAAAAANG
This thing is my classic go-to
because it's reliable,
it's got six shots
which is one more than the Hammershot.
Shoots pretty dang
*shoots invisible guy again*
pretty dang far as well.
Yeah, but can you load it with one hand?
You can't load it with one hand.
That's the only problem.
But who's really using two guns anyway?
This is my honorable mention
because this is the gun I had the
highest hopes and dreams for.
The Sledgefire.
You open up the chamber here,
and you actually have these little capsules.
these little clips that have three darts.
And you load it like that
And it's so cool. It shoots 3 at a time.
And it's
*shoots invisible guy holding the camera*
It's pretty cool, right?
It's just, the problem is that
It's really slow to load.
And also, you can only hold like
three of these little clips here at the same time.
Conceptually, this is like the coolest
most stylish one to have.
Roughcut.
Worst gun on the market.
Three darts came out!
Only two are supposed to come out
And now, see how this one's part way out?
It won't even shoot now.
*invisible guy finds a Nerf dart in his lunch*
Gross!
Get outta here.
What's the next most overrated gun?
There's one.
Nerf ball CC ball action, dude.
You have to
Gotta get
Think it's broke.
You know what that sound
You know what that sound is?
That's the sound of a breaking Nerf gun
after 200 rounds.
Your best bet is simplicity.
You know, this gun's pretty sweet actually.
It's giant.
It's mega.
It's got the most satisfying bolt action in the world.
And when it shoots,
the bolt inside
releases.
Got it working.
So this one's
you can actually just pump it
like you would, like, a squirt gun.
Whereas all these other ones
you only have a fixed amount of air
that you can put into the chamber,
whereas this one you keep pumping
until it can't go anymore.
Dude, you pumped it too much!
This one's has like an insane rate of fire
This one's my modded full-auto Nerf gun.
No one's ever seen it work
because I've never used it in a video.
Because it's too unfair.
How can you forget THE Mega?
This is THE Mega.
It's like one of the first mega dart launchers
that came out.
It only holds three shots.
Super reliable.
*shoots at invisible guy but hits Wren instead*
*hits invisible guy this time*
*shoots Wren this time, SOMEBODY STOP THIS MAN*
Getting hit in the eye with this would hurt a lot.
Walk.
Turn.
Gotcha!
So the rules of Nerf said
that if you say that you hit somebody
they must call themselves out.
So it keeps everybody honorable.
It keeps the games level-headed.
Walk.
And turn.
GOT YOU. I GOT YOU.
Dude, I accidentally uh
accidentally fanned the hammer.
One extra dart came out.
It went like
What's up, man?
Nothing.
Like, literally nothing?
Yeah. Literally nothing.
Nothing's happening right now.
Jake
Yeah?
Can we talk for a second?
Yeah, what's up?
I got a weird note on my doorstep last night?
On your door?
Yeah.
They know where I live.
This right here?
Yeah.
Do you have any idea who this could be?
I have a couple guesses.
Hey, man
What's up?
Nothing much, man. Just cuttin' this.
You know anything about this?
No, no I don't know anything about that, son.
You seen this before?
I've never seen that before in my life before, son.
It says that you're forcibly going to shave him?
With malice? Intentionally?
No.
You know that's assault, right?
Look man, I'm a beard guy.
You know that.
You know that if I had anyone
threaten what I got goin' on right here
I'd say that's a score that would need settling.
Sure, yeah.
Beard looks good on you though.
And I wouldn't do that to you, as a beard guy.
I didn't leave that on Ben's doorstep if that's what you're gettin' at.
I've seen this a couple times.
It never ends well.
The problem is, for me
no one will give me any information
and I'm afraid that not only is it cutting into productivity
but something's gonna break out at the office.
I gotta find a way to stop this.
Now.